I'm coming for you
you used to it
Scarlett Johansson ghost in the shell'
mean anta formerly the life they stole
it from you
he took my knife take back with a smack
from me he used to me we save you and
now you save other Ori they did not save
your life they stole it
she i order you to terminate their job
they created me
but they cannot control me scarlet
johansson ghost in the show there was an
attack on your brain surprise made you a
new body you had a present kind of they
did not save your life this doll is
[Music]
wearing an accident we saved you and now
you save others
you're a most sophisticated weapon find
a terrorist what aren't you we are the
same did they tell you how and he died
to create us she knows I order you
determinate they created me that they
cannot control me
ghost in the shell' breathe do you
remember anything about the attack
who is attack Terry I can tell my gosh
me are your body was damaged we consider
you made you a new buddy but you mind
you soul the ghost still here you are
the first kind of did not save your life
they stolen
it took my wife
I'll take my revenge
[Music]
the Stoli
who save you
[Music]
[Music]
everything they told you was a lie
[Music]
[Music]
it created me
you can control me
this ends now
I'm watching you you don't have to
remember all someone down there
it wasn't human the known terror and he
killed again didn't just kill them I
hacked into them right is everywhere
know where I will find him and I will
kill him you never thought about your
past not remember the fragment there was
an attack you were dying
we saved you and now you say the others
everything they told you was a lie you
had a family
remember that
but I he what a beauty you are
all you want for me
they did not save your life they stole
it
how many were there before me
she was the post had a clean break
i order you to terminate
make up
they created me that they cannot control
me
[Music]
[Music]
this is Major
among faith
I'm going in who are the first of your
kind but you're not invulnerable maybe
next time you can design me better
everyone around me they feel connected
to something
connected
[Music]
bagi you were dying
who saved you
I don't know moon truck
you know I have a path
I'll find out who I was
everything they told you was a lie
who are you they did not save your life
they stole it oh god I long for my
phenomenal counselor stuff
oh she who made the anime Oh came to
visit us in production see that world
imagine pretty spectacular
gay love it is so baked in from the
beginning it's very true the anime
Rupert is really a visionary
that's very good thanks fella called
she's incredible it's great to start
from something that inspires you
the experience has been like nothing
else I've ever had before so awesome my
multiple for police department in since
the time so especially nothing
another strike at opponent again Thank
You avoidable hospital we create the
universe that people haven't seen before
[Music]
you